you're not gonna believe this but
Americans do not trust the media the
media's doing such a good job all the
time people don't trust them I don't
know why uh Pew Research came out with a
poll uh which news organizations are
trustworthy and not trustworthy let's
take a look so believe it or not CNN the
most trusted name in news that's what
they tell us they are they are the most
trusted according to to 54% uh
respondents believe that that CNN is
trustworthy only 20% said untrustworthy
and then you know you see the the other
big networks ABC NBC CBS all kind of
hovering around the 52:46 area then the
cable news ones jump in a little bit
less I thought the one that was
interesting here Fox News 44% MSNBC 38%
I guess it depends who you like as to
who you trust New York Times down at 34%
and then some of the other interesting
ones daily show you know everyone says
the young people get their information
from The Daily Show but only 16% of
these respondents said they trust The
Daily Show 15 percent for Colbert uh
Hannity and Limbaugh not doing well 12
percent they're screaming all the time
and they're not doing that well a Drudge
Report only eight percent uh and then
finally I want to stop with BuzzFeed
only two percent I get a lot of stories
from BuzzFeed before this show at this
point and I generally think they're
pretty good only two percent there
they're like the hip cool thing other
even partnered with CNN who's number one
on this list so I what BuzzFeed told me
that the Gilmore Girls character I was
was Suki and clearly I'm gypsy so I
don't trust them anymore that that does
make sense so it goes self-reported
Paul's guy what is the demographic that
was pulled because you know I think that
something that's important sure what if
they were pulling all sort of older
people you know and obviously older
people don't watch or trust The Daily
Show as much as you know Millennials but
yeah it's interesting that CNN would be
the most trusted yet it always comes in
second or third in relation to Fox in
terms of viewership yeah different
people have a weird thing with CNN right
like I feel like everyone want the
reason I make fun of CNN so much is
because I want it to be better you know
to me like we all know what Fox News is
on the right and we know at MSNBC is on
the left so I when I have when I watch
television I want to trust something so
then when they do all the
Nickolas plane coverage or just the
endless 24-hour news cycle when they've
nothing to report on they say we're not
gonna speculate they spend the next hour
spectate I always want them to be better
yeah I think that's partly what's going
on your people I trust them but just I
trust them the most out of all this
other it's successful branding I think
people like the idea of CNN more than
they like CNN more than they watch CNN
yeah and so I think there's this idea of
it being kind of the way people used to
think of the New York Times as the paper
of record you know the Gray Lady you
know I think CNN has that kind of like
Bayer Aspirin brand trustworthiness even
though people are actually buying the
you know the generic because it's
cheaper yeah yeah I agree what do you
guys make the fact that all the digital
stuff is so low so buzz fee that we
talked about but all of them I mean
HuffPo TYT wasn't even on there I mean
what why is it that all this stuff is so
low because to me it seems like online
is like is actually the last bastion we
can get some some freedom and some
honesty and yet people are still
reporting that I think that's the
problem with digital media that like
everybody is just looking for you know
everybody's always like publishing
organizations like BuzzFeed post ages
pumping out clickbait more and more and
uh I think that compromises the quality
of the reporting yeah and again I would
do I I think you're going on your point
from before I'd like to see who got this
poll who did you ask because you know if
it yeah if they're 25 to 38 or or higher
then yeah they're not watch Miller then
I can be getting news online but I'd say
younger certainly are you should do a
poll on trustworthy polls that would be
that would give us some something there
uh how do you guys decide who to trust I
mention this every week that I don't
know what to trust anymore who to trust
I go to all these sites i watch all
these news things and usually by the end
of any report I'm thinking that was half
[ __ ] had every are you know how do
you decide who to get your news from in
a way that makes sense to you know sadly
like most people I think I probably just
whatever whatever matches my you know
the biases I thought it would in the
first place you know much like any fox
news watcher just it's a different bias
yeah yeah I tend to um like it with I'm
interested in topic I'll look at its
Wikipedia for one to get a 30,000 foot
sort of broad gist of what's going on
uh and then I spent a lot of time on
Google I try to form my own hypothesis
of whatever that issue is yeah um again
like I go to cnn.com I think CNN is is
great again you know I think that
they're they're already awesome I think
their potential is is limitless do you
guys think that the biggest problem we
have in America is the failure of the
media you know we talk about money in
politics and I know all this stuff is
interconnected and our politicians are
all bought nobody's honest and blah blah
but that the media has just utterly
failed us so we don't even have an
informed public to have the proper
debates which maybe explains why these
numbers are also tell we we lost Ben
Bradlee this week you know who is one of
the great bastions of of you know
journalism at its peak in this country
or one of its zenith uh yeah I mean I
think obviously the corporatization of
news the fact that you know what-what
Network told us thirty years ago over
forty years ago you know about how when
news entertainment combined when news
have to get ratings when news has to
sell advertising then yeah that then it
becomes another show and um you know I
think given that you know when you look
at what is Rupert Murdoch own and what
does you know these very small handfuls
of people who control a great deal of
the mass media uh obviously there's
gonna be a filtration process where you
know I wonder sometimes even I love
Rachel Maddow on MSNBC and I think is
she really gonna tell me about GE you
know of course and all the contracts
that they have with military things and
you know it never said and yet I was
like what when you ask people what is
they want they'll usually say vegetables
but if you watch them quietly go they'll
go for the candy instead and I think
that people just need to be more sort of
proactive and vocal about the kind of
news that they want
you